في السودان شوارع اسواق تبدو حركتها عاديه
لكن داخل ازقتها مرض يجول ساكنها
ففي هذا المكان تحديدا الصوره مختلفه
سيارات اسعاف تقف على اهبه الاستعداد
وممرات المستشفيات بات التعج بالمرضى
فشبح حمى الضنك لم يعد يميز بين كبير
وصغير ولا بين ولايه واخرى
ارقام فلكيه كشفت عنها وزاره الصحه
السودانيه فحالات الاصابه بهذا المرض
بلغت سته الاف وخمسمائه في ثلاثه عشره
ولايه احنا بنحتاج لانه يكون العمل شامل
لكل الولايه لانه في بؤر ممكن تكتشف فهي
لحظه انتشار المرض يبدو انه اصبح امرا
واقعا
فالاصابات وصلت العاصمه الخرطوم وللدقه
اكثر مناطق ام درمان وام بده وكرري غربي
العاصمه في وقت يعاني النظام الصحي فيه
ازمات انهكت كاهله كما نعلم ان النظام
الصحي في السودان يعاني كثير من التحديات
مما يستدعي التعاون مع الجهات العالميه
وزاره الصحه السودانيه اتخذت التدابير
اللازمه لمجابهه المرض والتقليل من حده
انتشاره لكنها حذرت من تفاقم الاوضاع
حلول موسم الخريف بعد اقل من شهرين